[Music]
in the arms
[Applause]
it's funny because he's fat with a bunch
of fat cry babies
one time on television I was castigated
by a debate opponent as skinny boy relax
skinny boy I got this that was
skinnyphobia back then there was a much
greater marger Scourge today that would
be of course fat phobia and the fine
people of tick tock have taken to
spreading the word about this terrible
malady
[Music]
now that I have your attention with that
video I would like to play a game and
Spot the Difference the video you just
saw versus this one that I'm about to
show you a screenshot of
in this video she's doing the same exact
trend
what's the difference
both wearing shorts
you know the difference I don't wanna I
know the difference I don't want to have
to you can't make me say that it's not
gonna tell me why I was shown this
notification I was scrolling through my
review page and I came across that video
do you think this video is appropriate
for younger users 13 to 17. yes I do not
showing them that video and showing them
this notification is inappropriate
you're telling them that their bodies if
they're larger are inherently sexual and
inappropriate that's the harmful message
stop it with this fat phobia I am so
tired of this app shaming large bodies
I'm done this is stupid the notification
is not saying that the video is
inappropriate the notification is asking
if you think this video is inappropriate
and presumably if enough people say that
it's inappropriate then they'll restrict
the video but the video is not
restricted frankly on these apps plenty
of that content should be banned and
restricted certainly for younger people
but it's not really the point right she
really shifts here at the end and she
says you know it's outrageous they're
targeting this larger person but what's
the difference what's the difference
what's the you know what the difference
is and it's impolite to note the
difference but yeah different things are
different Derek Jeter gets up to the
plate takes a swing at a fastball it's
going to look a certain way people are
probably going to want to watch that
he's a really good athlete if I step up
to the plate even an Adonis like me and
I take a swing at that fastball I'm not
going to hit it but I it it hit
the bat
it's not going to be quite as
interesting to watch okay we'd both be
swinging the bat we both have the
fastball but we're different we look
different our bodies are a little bit
different and people would be more or
less inclined to watch us in a physical
feat that is very true I love how her
conclusion though is that no we need to
especially have the larger person be
presented to Little Children can't how
about what if we just restrict the
scintillating content for everybody for
all of it when it's the larger people
well it's the skinnier people when it's
even skinnier boys like me okay next one
how do I deal with feeling fat shamed at
doctor's appointments I get this
question a lot and first of all I'm
sorry this really shouldn't happen
unfortunately it does so let's talk
about how to navigate it and get you
more out of your doctor's appointments
my advice to you is put yourself in the
driver's seat you dictate to your
provider what you do and do not want to
talk about at the start of your visit
try something like this hi nice to see
you I'm here today for UTI I'm aware
that I'm overweight I'm not really here
to talk about that today and I would
appreciate it if we could just focus on
the reason that I came in if you're
there for routine checkup expect to talk
about your weight it's a part of it but
bring it up yourself let them know what
your goals are for your weight I'll do
another post about my approach to
talking about weight with patients it
doesn't have to be judgy or shameful
judgy that's a clinical term that people
learn in medical school I don't really
go to doctors very much but sometimes
Elisa does make me go and I can't wait
to walk in next time hey Doc how's it
going I know it's been a while look I
don't want to talk about the cigars and
I don't want to talk about the booze and
I don't want to talk about the fatty
Italian Meats yeah I don't want to talk
about any of that so other than that
how's my health
they'll say well other than all the
problems I guess your health is fine
great can't wait to tell my wife that
thanks Doc where do I make my copay
that's that's just what I came here for
that's why you go to a doctor is to be
told everything you want to hear if you
were talking about problems he might
diagnose something and that's not what
you wanted a doctor's office right now
head on over to jenucell.com Knowles YT
did you know that our friends over at
genucel have upgraded their most popular
package to feature their top selling
deep firming vitamin C serum plus Ultra
retinol moisturizer with natural retinol
alternative did you know that now you do
and right now you can take advantage of
this limited time package upgrade for
seventy seven zero percent off why waste
time and money to go get work done to
your face when you can get geniusell
skin care shipped right to your door
here's a genucel.com review from Robert
in blessing Texas quote I purchased
geniusell as a gift for my girlfriend
she said she saw the results so fast her
skin is noticeably softer and smoother I
can see and feel a difference too she
was already beautiful and geniusell has
made her more beautiful geniusell's
secret is a family recipe for over 20
years that makes it safe for all skin
types and a perfect for both men and
women it's made by a compounding
pharmacist in small batches the owner is
great he started out in Egypt he's a
Coptic Christian left for the American
dream head on over to geniusell.com
Knowles YT trigenous most popular
package for seventy percent off
featuring both geniusell's Ultra retinol
and geniusell's Firming Serum get a
complimentary spy Essentials box with
every package order plus free up Bridge
priority shipping that is geniusell.com
Knowles y t being body positive is not
an excuse to neglect your health
I've seen other people Stitch your video
and they were much nicer to you than I'm
going to be you have no idea who I am so
let me introduce myself I am an exercise
physiologist which means I hold a degree
in this field a certification in this
field and mostly professional did she
say she's an exorcist physiologist
[Music]
what did she say I'm an exercise
physiologist which means I hold a degree
in this field a certification in this
field and an exercise physiologist maybe
maybe
[Music]
in fact one of my jobs was actually
managing a gym where I hired trained and
fired personal trainers just like you
and I mean that literally you're not
special a thin white young able-bodied
personal trainer is quite literally a
dime a dozen especially ones with such
spicy literally there are literally
markets that price you at 10 cents per
dozen of you literally I learned that in
exorcism physiology school okay and you
know what I'm not going to be nice to
you or Pleasant at all
so there you don't know me so I'll
introduce myself she says into the void
it's just a woman venting her anger at
the world screaming up at the sky I've
been exercising physiologist I hate
reality takes like fat bad unhealthy you
need lose weight with exercise me make
you and a significant misunderstanding
of body positivity on top of it
I need you to start wrapping your head
around the idea that people can pursue
Fitness without a weight loss goal
including fat people your attitude and
approach is exactly what keeps a lot of
people away from Fitness
good luck on your exam I don't know what
has happened in This Woman's life put
aside the fat thing or whatever for a
second the phobia is
if you find yourself with this attitude
just stop stop whatever you're doing
go seek help turn inward think about
what has gone wrong in your life to give
you this demeanor all the time to just
be on edge and you know you're just
ready to go start screaming about and
insulting all these strangers and you
just it doesn't that's not
this is my health advice
I am not a physiologist I do not
exercise and I do not perform exorcisms
but my health advice to you would be
calm down it's okay it's all right
there's more to life than just getting
angry at Tick Tock or something
you can laugh at Tick Tock which is if
you're gonna do anything with Tick Tock
that's what I would recommend you do
okay next one when are we gonna stop
allowing skinny people to claim they
have body dysmorphia so they can be
aggressively fat phobic as because
I'm so tired the arguments worn out
people are allowed to be insecure she's
not fat phobic she has body dysmorphia
the body positivity movement was made
for all bodies first of all let's shift
the conversation to body neutrality
second of all the voices that she's sort
of mocking
as being tedious or cliche who says that
where do these conversations take place
and take place so frequently that they
could become cliche and tedious that
this woman would mock them oh you know
activity movement and that's why we need
to stop accusing them of being fat for
me like ah blah blah blah here at last I
hear it right don't you I don't know
what a number of those terms even really
mean what communities is this woman
living in she's saying that the skinny
people who have body problems
should not be given any sympathy because
we should Reserve all of the sympathy
for the fat people with body problems I
guess keep going pretty sure movements
are created for oppressed and
marginalized people you know fat bodies
disabled bodies trans bodies people of
color bodies those bodies and uh I
highly doubt every fat phobic piece
has a disorder also no one said
disorders can't be problematic matter of
fact a lot are so maybe instead of using
that as a defense mechanism to deflect
the blame
try and learn it I get a kick out of her
a lot she reminds me of this gal who
also had a nose ring right in the center
of her nose who made a whole video with
the same attitude making fun of me and
she also used profane and vulgar
language in exactly the same way like
are you so effing dumb they're almost
like the same person they almost
certainly run in the same kind of
ideological circles and they're both
funny this is this is a really a great
glimpse into an entire community that I
just don't spend any time in can you
teach me speaker like you communities
are defined in no small part by language
because language is the stuff of our
Consciousness it it not only colors but
in some ways constitutes the way that we
view the world and so that's why the
libs are always so intent on making us
use their crazy language is to transform
not only what we can say but what we can
even think and set the limits of what we
can think and and this is why they
established taboos and standards as well
Luca
here the the concepts the taboos the
standard certainly but even just the
concepts that she's talking about are
just foreign to my understanding of the
world I was really that was delightful
do we have any more it just dawned on me
how many people don't understand how
rarely fat people actually receive
evidence-based medicine from doctors one
time I went in for an ear infection and
the doctor told me to lose weight you
know what thin people get antibiotics
one time I found a lump did she not also
get antibiotic appointment to get a
cancer screening it was at an OB GYN and
as soon as the doctor walked in he
didn't look at me he didn't introduce
himself he looked at my chart and he
said you'd have an easier time getting
pregnant if you lost weight
I told him I'm not here for fertility
treatment I'm here for a cancer
screening and he said oh okay and
started the appointment never said sorry
and I would need to make a 20-part
series for the Saga I went through last
year when I needed spinal surgery for a
life long spinal defect that had nothing
to do with my weight and this is the
norm
it's typical for this to happen it's the
norm because there are norms and so
when you fall outside of the norm
and then you go see a physician whose
job it is to encourage you to get a
little bit closer to the norm
they will point that out to you
and then you will be upset you say how
dare you suggest that there are norms
and that it is normal to be nearer to
the norms
why would you do that you're a physician
you should just tell me whatever I want
to hear and I'm not going to tell you
what I want to hear you need to guess it
and if you guess it wrong I hate you and
I'm going to make a tick tock about how
much I don't like you my favorite one by
far was the black lady with the nose
ring she had the funniest Vibe and the
most delightful diction she also wasn't
fat right you can only see her from the
neck up she looked very skinny which
adds even more complexity and richness
to her Tick Tock see you next time folks
skinny boy
[Music]
fine
who's fat